disney's live-action mulan is an epic
action film that's filled with tons of
deep cut references to the original
animation
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing 52 of the best
disney easter eggs and hidden details to
look out for in the new movie
plus where to find the secret tributes
to the indestructible mooshu
some spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet
the opening disney logo has been
transformed with some cool new details
appropriate to milan
the iconic fairy tale castle has been
given some chinese style architectural
additions
and just behind that is a long wall a
reference to the opening scene of the
animated movie where the huns begin
their invasion by scaling the great wall
of china
a shining phoenix also replaces a
shooting star that normally arcs over
the castle
a nice touch given mulan's connection
with the mythological beast in the new
movie
the shape-shifting sorceress played by
gong li is a cool new character added to
this version of the story
and in her very first scene we get a
hint at how her arc will parallel
mulan's as she disguises herself by
merging with the body of a man on the
silk road
just like our heroine will later pretend
to be a man in order to join the
imperial army
the sorceress's name shen yang as well
as her character arc are also hat tips
to a 17th century chinese novel in which
a princess of the same name captured
mulan but then they became bonded
sisters when mulan revealed her true
identity to her
in disney's movie although mulan and the
sorceress start out as enemies they gain
respect for one another and ultimately
become
allies although the sorceress can
shapeshift into various forms she
frequently turns into a hawk
and so resembles shangyu's falcon
sidekick from the animated movie
and there are loads of incredible
hawk-like details on her costume from
her long feather-like skirt
to her belt made from bones and then
there's her fearsome looking hawk
crown she also has talon-shaped daggers
that she can toss with deadly force
and she can even grow bird-like claws on
her fingers that she uses to slash at
her enemies
i could tear you to pieces before you
blink plus
according to the film's director nikki
carro her makeup is hooded like a hawks
in the form of a white mask with the use
of the colour white
being significant because in china white
is the colour of death and also the
colour of purity
ming now when the voice of the animated
mulan makes an awesome cameo to the tune
of reflection
as she presents her live action
counterpart to the emperor your imperial
highness
hua mulan ming na wen's official credit
in the movie is as esteemed guest which
is a lovely way to acknowledge the
legacy of the original disney film that
the new movie builds upon
if you look at the train of her dress
really closely you can spot a phoenix
another nice detail connecting both
disney mulans together
more on the other hidden phoenix's and
their true meaning in the movie later
and the green and red colors of mingna
wen's ceremonial dress
also appeared to be a nod to the colours
of the outfit that the animated mulan
wore in front of the emperor as well as
the various shades of green she wore
during the animation
everyone's favorite animated talking
dragon mushu may not have made it into
the live-action movie but the filmmakers
still wanted to honour him by including
ancestral dragons in the film
and you'll find them on various fabrics
and weapons
so watch the scene closely when mulan's
father goes to sharpen the family sword
because the stone he uses
is wrapped in a cloth with an
embroidered picture of a dragon
also during milan's confrontation with
the sorceress you can spot a dragon on
the guard of milan's ancestral sword
and then there's a dragon on the hilt of
the sword that's gifted to milan by the
emperor at the end of the movie
there's also a sneaky nod to one of
mushu's most memorable lines from the
animated film
when the garrison sergeant tells the
troops what will before them if they are
found being dishonest
disgrace disgrace for you disgrace for
your family
disgrace for your village disgrace for
your country this honor this honor on
your whole family make a note of this
dishonor on you
design on your cow and mulan's new
mythological guardian the phoenix is
predominantly red yellow
and purple a hat tip to mushu's colours
in the 90's classic
another of mulan's animated sidekicks
was kriki the allegedly lucky cricket
like mushu cricky doesn't appear in the
new movie however there is a human
character called cricket that joins the
army at the same time as mulan
my mother says i was born under an
auspicious moon
yep this cricket's a lucky one cricket
does seem to have good fortune
despite all the new recruits being
terrible archers he's able to hit the
target even with his eyes closed
and he gets an awesome moment protecting
mulan and clearing a path for her when
he takes out two roaring soldiers with
one lucky shot from his bow
like the animated qrikey he also
miraculously survives a potentially
fatal accident during the avalanche
scene
man you are one lucky bug and again
during the final showdown at the
imperial city to everyone's relief we
discover cricket really does enjoy good
fortune just like his animated
counterpart also survived the final
battle
you are a lucky bird and fun fact if you
didn't already know
qrikets are viewed as symbols of good
fortune in china and were kept as pets
from early antiquity
however crickey was so unpopular among
many of disney animations filmmakers at
the time of the original film as he
almost
ended up scrapped from the movie the
ever so memorable musical numbers from
the animation didn't make it into the
live-action version but there are still
numerous references to the iconic songs
the popular i'll make a man out of you
is referenced when the garrison sergeant
says
we're going to make men out of every
single one of you
that's followed by a training montage
that pays homage to the scene that
accompanied the song and the animation
for example when the recruits miserably
fail to get anywhere near the targets
with their bow and arrow it's very
similar to the original film
they also have to carry heavy pails of
water up a mountain
similar to the weights they were made to
carry in the animation in the new movie
this bucket challenge replaces the pole
climb and unlike the animated mulan who
struggled carrying weights up the
mountain
this new challenge is the one where she
shines and proves her worth
the interesting difference here is that
it's mulan's qi that powers her up the
mountain whereas in the animation it was
her ingenuity and determination in
figuring out how to repurpose the
weights that helped her scale the log
at the heart of both the live-action and
animated mulan movies
is the idea of being true to who you
really are the song reflection is a core
part of that theme in the animation and
the new movie pays tribute to that with
an instrumental version which plays at
key moments
so when mulan is summoned to her
commanding officer as he begins to
explain how
only the most true connect to their chi
the tune from reflection is woven into
the music playing in the background
the moment is not only a great easter
egg but it also adds an extra emotional
layer to the scene
with reflection continuing to play over
the montage of mulan learning to
reconnect with her chi
and finishing as she reaches the summit
of the mountain
[Music]
and that montage also includes several
visual nods to when the animated mulan
sang the song for the first time
as the camera lingers over her
reflection in the water and also a
nearby magnolia tree
there's also a second musical reference
during the sequence with a shout out to
a line from i'll make a man out of you
when commander tong
says tranquil was a forest but on fire
with him you'll also hear reflection
during mulan's next big moment which
comes just after her confrontation with
the sorceress when hua zhen dies and the
true mulan
is born as she looks into her sword she
sees her own reflection together with
the word
true and then the instrumental theme
strikes up again
as she sheds her false identity and
reveals her true self
the theme of reflection and being true
to yourself has even carried into the
very final scene of the new movie when
mulan looks into the blade of her new
sword and sees herself and the phoenix
reflected back at her
this is in sharp contrast to the start
of the film just before she meets the
matchmaker when she looks in the mirror
and sees a version of herself that
doesn't reflect who she really is
another shout out to the animated movie
comes at the garrison when ling looks at
a scroll of a girl
which recalls how the song a girl worth
fighting for started off in the
animation
that's what i said a girl worth fighting
for
and when the men start discussing who
their ideal woman would be
poe says i don't care what she looks
like i agree i
care what she cuts like very similar to
what was said in the animated movie
i couldn't care less what she'll wear or
what she looks like
it all depends on what she cooks like
the embarrassing moment for milan when
she enters the tent and poe drops his
towel
is a humorous call back to the
animation's lake scene when mulan had to
avert her eyes after yao climbed onto a
rocks dark naked
i am yao king of the rock
and there's nothing you girls can do
about it
and there's a short instrumental version
of the song honor to us all
when mulan is primped and polished to go
to the matchmaker in tribute to the
original film
[Music]
the magnolia tree by the lake in the
live-action movie
and the blossoms that the camera focuses
on when mulan goes to bathe for a sweet
call back to the magnolia tree from the
animated film and a crucial moment in
that story when milan's father told her
this one's late but i'll bet that when
it blooms
it will be the most beautiful of all
mulan's name actually means magnolia and
chinese which is why the flower is so
thematically important in both the
disney movies
for example the film's costume designer
added a large embroidered magnolia
blossom to the center of the
undergarment mulan wurs as part of her
matchmaker outfit
and when she practices her sword work
and learns to connect with her chi
she does so near the magnolia tree by
the lake
mulan's matchmaker outfit also has
embroidered images of the phoenix which
are a nice nod to the crucial role the
mythological beast plays for our heroine
in this version of the story
the choice to use of phoenix is mulan's
guardian in the new movie is especially
interesting because as we see in the
emperor's throne room the phoenix sits
to his right while the dragon sits to
his left
and of course mulan's journey takes her
to the imperial city where she saves his
life
in china the phoenix has often been
viewed as a symbol of the empress or a
female member of the royal family while
the dragon represented the emperor
with the two together representing a
harmonious and balanced relationship
in addition to that in chinese mythology
the phoenix was
originally two separate birds one male
and one female
though they later merged to become one
and so the duality of the phoenix makes
it a perfect guardian and symbol for
mulan who is a woman
takes on what's perceived to be a
traditionally male role in the story
and there are also so many call backs
and little twists on moments from the
original movie
one of my favorites is when mulan
returns to the army to deliver news
about bori khan's secret plan to attack
the imperial city
commander tong says it's foolish to
listen to her given she was dishonest
about who she really was to which hong
koe replies
you would believe hajoon why do you not
believe hamburglar it's a line that
echoes what mulan said in her own
defense in the animated movie
you said you'd trust ping why is mulan
any different
then when she faces off against bori
khan without a sword and uses her skills
and smarts to take it from him
it's a callback to how she used her
quick thinking to wrangle shanyu's sword
from him
defeating him in the animation it looks
like you're out of ideas
not quite and the single soldier who
survives bori khan's attack at the
beginning of the film and delivers the
news of the defeat to the imperial city
this soldier is the only survivor is a
throwback to how chanyu decided only one
man was needed to deliver his message to
the emperor
how many men does it take to deliver a
message one
as well as disney easter eggs the new
movie also includes a few shout outs the
original ballad of mulan that the story
is based on
when the adult mulan arrives home at the
beginning of the film she tells her
parents about two rabbits that were
running alongside her while she was out
riding
i think one was a male one was a female
but you know you can't really tell when
they're running that fast mulan's
comment isn't just a reference to the
theme of gender roles in the story
it's also a nice hat tip to the original
ballad which ends with the lines two
rabbits running close to the ground
how can they tell if i am male or female
and when we see mulan's little sister
busy at the loom at the start of the
film
it's a nod to how the original poem
starts off with mulan herself weaving at
a loom
i really like some of the bold creative
choices in the new movie
and in my other mulan video i do a deep
dive into the best and worst differences
in the live action film compared to
disney's animation
tap here to watch that next or follow
the link in the video description
so did you spot any other easter eggs or
interesting details in the new movie
and what were your favorite moments
comment with your thoughts below
if you enjoyed this don't forget to
leave a thumbs up it really helps and i
hugely appreciate it
tap left for my formula and disney live
action playlist or tap write for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee guy movie lovers